comme tous les bons fans de
science-fiction 2022 pour moi c'était
pas les drones et le métaverse c'était
l'exploration interplanétaire voir
intergalactique
[Musique]
j'ai tapé planète extraterrestre sur
Internet et après avoir fait bonne usage
de mon esprit critique je me suis rendu
compte qu'on était en fait à un des
moments les plus passionnants de
l'histoire des sciences les astronomes
étaient en train de découvrir des
planètes à la pelle des exoplanètes
[Musique]
des planètes qui orbitent autour
d'autres étoiles quelque part dans la
galaxie alors bien sûr l'existence de
ces planètes orbitants autour d'autres
étoiles étaient théoriquement connu
depuis très longtemps mais jusque dans
le milieu des années 90 le fait d'en
détecter réellement une restait de la
science-fiction c'est précisément en
1995 qu'on a découvert la première
exoplanète du nom poétique de 51 Pegasi
B depuis on en a découvert 5000 en 25
ans ça fait en moyenne une tous les deux
jours j'étais en transe même si bon j'ai
vite compris plusieurs choses déjà
j'allais jamais voir de mon vivant une
belle image d'exoplanète genre celle
qu'on a ramené de Pluton il y a pas très
longtemps et mes enfants non plus et
leurs enfants non plus et puis pour ce
qui est d'y aller alors là
mais plus question de déprimer alors
j'ai décroché mon téléphone et j'ai
appelé un astronome directement
spécialiste des exoplanètes et c'est
comme ça que je me suis retrouvé à
l'Observatoire de Paris sur le site de
Meudon pour discuter avec des chercheurs
qui travaillent au lézia le laboratoire
d'études spatiales et d'instrumentation
en astrophysique
[Musique]
les scientifiques qui conçoivent les
instruments dont Kepler Newton aurait
même pas pu rêver je voulais savoir
quelle découverte ils allaient faire eux
pour pouvoir nous faire rêver nous alors
vous avez pas beaucoup de temps alors
déjà il y a des planètes autour de
toutes les étoiles en fait à peu près
oui et du coup à chaque fois que vous
regardez une étoile maintenant vous vous
voyez les planètes
avec toutes les techniques que vous avez
vu vous devez réussir à avoir quasiment
toutes les planètes en réalité on
utilise plusieurs techniques mais une
planète c'est relativement éloignée de
nous c'est très faible et sa situe à
côté d'un objet très brillant qui est
l'étoile donc c'est difficile même avec
des instruments très puissants c'est un
peu comme essayer de regarder une
luciole à côté d'un lampadaire qui se
trouvera à deux bornes quoi ouais alors
on dirait plutôt voir une luciole à côté
d'un phare en Bretagne depuis Moscou et
encore faut pas qu'il y ait du
brouillard ah c'est pour ça que vous
mettez les télescopes dans le désert ou
en montagne au milieu du Pacifique oui
ou alors on peut aussi les relier entre
eux avec plusieurs télescopes où on peut
envoyer le télescope dans l'espace
depuis les années 70 des dizaines de
télescopes ont été envoyés dans l'orbite
terrestre pour observer l'univers sous
toutes les coutures sous toutes les
longueurs d'ondes le plus connu très
certainement jusqu'à maintenant
s'appelle Hubble et fait la taille d'un
bus avec tous ces télescopes en orbite
je me disais qu'on avait dû mettre la
main sur pas mal de planètes qui
ressemblait potentiellement à la terre
mais alors du coup s'il y avait une
jumelle de la Terre à l'autre bout de la
galaxie on pourrait la voir ou pas en
fait les exoplanètes qu'on connaît elles
se trouvent dans un rayon de 400
années-lumière autour de la Terre alors
que la Voie Lactée mesure 100 000
années-lumière et puis une planète comme
la terre c'est pas grand
et c'est la luciole ouais alors dans
l'exemple de la luciole on pensait même
plutôt à une planète comme Jupiter voir
plus gros et puis ben si on veut avoir
des informations sur l'atmosphère d'une
planète il faut pouvoir capter la
lumière qu'elle nous aimait ou qu'elle
réfléchit de l'étoile
pas juste détecter sa présence mais mais
la voir quoi ben oui et ça c'est mort
non c'est pas mort c'est justement sur
ça qu'on travaille Anthony m'a emmené
voir son collègue Johan trop sympa donc
ça a été inventé à l'Observatoire de
Paris il y a 100 ans pour observer le
soleil et là maintenant on l'a détourné
pour s'en servir pour cacher les étoiles
très brillantes et observer les planètes
qui sont très peu brillantes juste à
côté dans les années 30 bernard-lieu
invente le coronographie
tout en haut du Pic du Midi dans le but
d'observer de la couronne solaire on a
du mal à se représenter la prouesse
technologique que c'était à l'époque
aujourd'hui Johan joue à peu près au
même jeu de cache-cache avec les photons
mais plus au niveau du système solaire
mais au niveau de la galaxie et donc bah
ce que tu vois c'est que pour le moment
on voit une image comme si on avait
l'étoile comme si on observait une
étoile à travers un télescope et ben là
je vais mettre le masque devant l'étoile
d'un coup ça fait disparaître la
luminosité de l'étoile et là on voit
apparaître la planète juste à côté alors
ça c'est le prototype de démo le vrai
instrument il est dans une salle blanche
vous savez ce que c'est une seule
planche c'est un endroit dans lequel on
essaie de contrôler la température la
pression d'enlever les vibrations et
surtout toutes les petites particules en
suspension pour faire des expériences
ultra précises et on évite évidemment
l'introduction de corps étrangers de
type moi
du coup j'étais trop content d'y aller
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît essayez de respirer
normalement sinon vous allez tomber dans
les pommes
vous allez pas me dire qu'avec un truc
comme ça vous cherchez que vous
extraterrestres
ici sauf que ici on a pas une vraie
étoile qu'on observe donc pour la
remplacer on va prendre un laser très
puissant qu'on va fixer sur un détecteur
et avec l'instrument coronographique on
va supprimer le laser de manière à ce
qu'elle est faim il n'y ait plus de
lumière du laser qui arrive sur la
caméra
donc ici sur le banc on simule donc tout
un instrument coronographique il y a pas
mal de pièces très précises et en
particulier des miroirs des formables
sur un centimètre carré plusieurs
centaines d'actionneurs bougent très
rapidement très précisément pour pouvoir
corriger la lumière qui arrive vous
rendez compte des miroirs d'un
centimètre carré déformé par des
centaines d'actionneurs dans l'espoir
d'éliminer la lumière qui vient
d'étoiles qui elles font plusieurs
millions de kilomètres de diamètre c'est
quand même incroyable donc ça c'est le
genre d'image qu'on obtient sur le banc
ici au centre c'était là où il y avait
l'étoile qui a été totalement supprimée
là c'est des tâches de lumière qui sont
créées par toute la lumière résiduelle
qui reste de l'étoile et ça c'est la
zone qu'on arrive à corriger où on peut
potentiellement trouver des planètes et
tu vois du coup qu'on peut réussir à la
tourner pour chercher autour donc là on
pourrait avoir apparaître Tatooine ou
Pandora quoi alors les petites planètes
comme la terre ou les satellites ça pour
le moment on a encore un peu de temps là
ce qu'on va surtout voir c'est des
grosses planètes de type Jupiter ou
alors des disques de débris alors on
parle de ça chez les petites photos de
[Musique]
en fait un instrument conçu ici au lézia
vient déjà de partir dans l'espace avec
le James web télescope le télescope
spatial le plus puissant de l'histoire
[Musique]
mais il va surtout permettre de faire de
l'observation directe et donner aux
astronomes plein d'informations sur les
atmosphères de ces autres mondes et
peut-être découvrir enfin une seconde
terre une autre planète habitable et
puis jeune a commencé à m'expliquer que
lui c'était pas tellement ce qui
l'animait mais alors même si on
détermine que la vie est possible dans
l'univers si on peut jamais y aller à
quoi sert à quoi ça sert juste pour
comprendre pour savoir c'est comme la
tectonique des plaques ou la théorie de
l'évolution ou la relativité générale au
début quand l'invente c'est juste de
savoir qui nous intéresse et puis on
sait pas exactement qu'est-ce que ça
peut nous amener non seulement en termes
de nouvelles innovations techniques et
même en plus pour savoir en fait pour la
révolution philosophique que ça
amènerait autant si on sait qu'on est
seul dans l'univers ou si on sait qu'il
y a une autre planète avec de la vie
dans l'univers et même en attendant moi
ce qui me fait rêver au jour le jour bah
c'est ça c'est la formation des planètes
c'est une un autre monde qui est en
écoutant parler avec autant de passion
de 10 de débris situés à des millions de
kilomètres de nous j'ai compris que
aucun astronome n'avait jamais ont été
motivé par l'idée de nous faire changer
de monde eux leur but c'est de changer
le monde de changer notre manière de le
voir notre manière de le comprendre
imaginez on estime à 20 milliards le
nombre de planètes rien que dans notre
galaxie les observations qui vont être
faites dans les décennies à venir vont
peut-être nous permettre de remettre en
cause nos paradigmes de Galilée à Newton
de Newton Einstein et après et comme si
c'est Johan à quoi serviront les
technologies les maths les idées les
concepts qui auront été développés en
chemin pour comprendre tout ça nous
aussi on a le droit de regarder le futur
en rêvent et comme disait Pierre Dac
rien n'est jamais complètement perdu
tant qu'il reste quelque chose à trouver
[Musique]